[Music]  I'm Trish Z and I'm directing pitch  perfect 3 I want to take you around the  set and give you a little sneak peek of  what's coming we're taking you on a  global tour with the Bellas  girl what's the weakness nice shoes  we're action stars here on the setup  page for v3 getting attacked by dogs I'm  also allergic to very great to be  spending the idea we're almost exactly  halfway through Russia right now  there are many people doing very  important things here we are not any of  them Gannicus hilarious rebel and John  are just like peas in a pod and dj  khaled is amazing he's a force of nature  DJ Kyle will be in the big movie pitch  perfect 3 2 I am the most badass Philip  I mean I have to run at least 10 steps  and this same last day of shooting for  me three all day  suffering emotional  mr. ladies there you go  [Music]  we're all gonna miss this  it's been a wild ride  [Music]  you